foreign
ERS podcast in the Dunya the three
Muslims before we get started on today's
stream we just got another quick
announcement so our collection dropped
so go get yours today the link is in the
description right now I'm wearing the
two-piece I got the sweater just like
the brother there and I got the
oversized tea as well that's what makes
it look so amazing
so keep in mind
in 13 days it will be closed and we will
not be releasing it again or more likely
when we sell out it will be closed and
we will not be releasing again and 10
percent of the profits go to the
measured being built in Norway and the
earthquake victims so click the link
support the merch I'll see you guys in a
second fayad bring everyone up inshallah
also known as the Muslim Lantern he
muted right now
it's finally happening man so I've seen
personally I've seen your content
um a little bit here and there for a
while now and I've always noticed
just such Elegance in your dawah and I'd
love inshallah to get into that but
first before we talk about the street
dawa which is what the people know you
for I want to talk a little bit about
the Muslim Lantern and why you started
dawa so
want me to just pull up on the street
one day and start teaching Islam
well I I think uh
I'm the type of person who doesn't like
to get a lot into personal issue and
stuff like that I'll give you a general
overview right so basically I think
family upbringing is a very important
thing that's why I personally think I
think it goes a long way into your
future as a human being how you're
raised how your family influenced you in
your young right when I was young I used
to my alhamdulillah I have a religious
parents they used to teach me about
Islam things like that and the
interesting thing is when I was young I
used to like
uh learning about Islam so I I used to
actually enjoy it I used to enjoy going
to the mosque listening to the lectures
of the scholars uh while while you see
like other children they would like to
go play soccer football Etc whenever my
father is going he says to me to come I
used to enjoy I used to go there you
used to always have this like
competition and then you have the Sheikh
he gives a reward whoever answers the
question stuff like I used to enjoy it
basically used to find it fun I used to
enjoy CK knowledge always so it was
something that was a part of my uh my
daily life right alhamdulillah I studied
in you can say throughout all my life I
was studying Islam since I was young
until I
reached the university and also studied
University Etc and then after that then
I've seen some uh
seen some Personalities in the Bible
scene I've seen people giving thou have
come across videos of the corner come
across different people given dawa and
that was always a passion for me to to
engage with someone speaking about Islam
obviously you listen to this Hadith with
the prophet is
one person accepting Islam through you
know it's better than you know anything
in the world if you want to put it in
that understanding of description right
so that was always on my mind and
because I used to enjoy Islam I wanted
to convey Islam so
and you can see that in in a country
like here like the UK we're not
fulfilling our obligations Muslims
conveying them as such a it's an issue
and you can say that throughout the
Muslims whoever is living in a
non-muslim country we're not fulfilling
our obligation unfortunately and there
is a high demand the highest demand I've
seen on Islam recently people are eager
to learn about the religion people are
so excited about Islam people they they
want to know what we believe in right
and we get sometimes people on the
dollar table they say we ask our Muslim
friends but they don't answer us
so it's not that we're not even doing
our job but that people are coming to us
and we're not answering them which is a
huge issue do you understand it's it's
like it come to that level that they're
so curious that they broke the barrier
of fear they are coming to you to ask
you about your own religion and you're
not providing them with information
you're not answering their questions Etc
so there is this obligation upon us all
as Muslims and we need to all keep this
verse of mind and the Quran Allah says
Let There be from among you a group of
people a nation a small group of people
or a group of people that call to good
and call Away From Evil and then Allah
finishes the verse with this beautiful
ending
those are the successful
so alhamdulillah I wanted to be from the
successful people you know if I can be
of Allah except for me to be from
amongst the successful people to do the
job of the messengers the thing that
Allah honor the prophets and The
Messengers and made them examples for
mine for mankind using and obviously
we're very deficient uh um not doing as
as I should be doing I'm not I'm
shouldn't be in that position to begin
with but when there is a need you have
to do something you have to at least
convey what you know so alhamdulillah
this is just a basic overview of the
reason why I got into that way
all right alhamdulillah so would you say
that Darwa is an obligation upon every
single Muslim whether you know they're
on the street or just at work or at
school
according to to the scholars so it's a
communal obligation which means a part
of the community has to fulfill that
obligation otherwise the full community
is selling
uh so for example like salatul Al
jenezer like for example the the prayer
of janaza you've got a group of Muslims
have to perform on the dead person if no
one performs it all the Muslims are
saying because no one is fulfilling that
Duty right but if our group fulfills it
then we don't need to do it too right
this is generally the ruling of tawa but
that ruling can change based on the
scenario situation that you're in if you
are in a scenario where someone needs
dawa he needs to learn about Allah he's
asking you about Allah and you've got
that knowledge then it becomes farther
becomes an obligation upon you as an
individual to deliver that message and
this is the problem in the west today we
a lot of us has become especially in
this country or depends on which country
or depends on your situation but it
becomes further I know upon you it
becomes an obligation upon you there are
people around you that you know are
doomed to attend our Hellfire if they
die as disbelievers
you can't just walk past them as as if
you don't care about their their
afterlife if you've got any Mercy in
your heart as a Believer then you have
to you will want to engage with those
people you won't as much as you can
obviously because knowledge is very
important we're not saying engage
without knowledge we're not saying speak
without knowledge you're not saying
because that can cause more harm than it
cause than it does good right but we're
saying for anyone who can convey
anything that he knows that he's certain
of it becomes an obligation for you at
least I usually say to the people look
if you're afraid that you don't have the
eloquence to engage with the people tell
them information about Islam and teach
them what you can easily do just give
them a copy of the Quran say look he
says here's my gift to you I thank you
how are you are you okay I've always
seen you you know and I wanted you to
learn about us and what Muslims believe
there you go do you like to read the
copy no one will say ever no no one will
say no to a gift you know everyone will
accept a gift so you can always do it
that way if you feel you're not able to
engage with them yourself
I'm not able to answer the questions
just give it to them if they then become
curious after reading and they start
asking you questions and you're not
qualified take them to someone who is go
take them at least or anyone that you
know who's knowledgeable who might be
able to engage with them teach them and
take them a step forward but yes in most
situations for Muslims who are in the
west these days I would say it becomes a
for the an obligation on each person
so as I said it all depends
so I'm imagining a situation like you
just painted someone goes to a regular
Muslim they ask a question you know they
see the person has a beard or they pray
or they see a sister in hijab and they
ask a question and the person doesn't
know
do you think that person should go back
home whether they interact with the you
know the non-muslim again or not should
they go back home and start learning
their Deen is seeking knowledge on Islam
to be able to answer these questions
also an obligation
yeah absolutely so that's another
obligation right and subhanallah
when he was he was given advice for for
the Muslims in in uh in the minorities
they were minorities and non-muslim
countries at that time he gave a full
lecture she's one and a half hour or
something like that I I would advise
anyone who speaks Arabic to listen to it
because it's very beneficial especially
for people on uh involved in the dark
right and he answers very common
questions to the things that we come we
come up uh on a daily basis as people
who try to do that way in the west right
and what he mentions is
you cannot do that well without
knowledge right he says
where Allah commands the prophet to say
this is my path
I call to Allah upon knowledge
me and also follow me those who follow
the same path they have to do the same
thing they have to be a pumble zero you
have to be upon knowledge you have to be
upon wisdom they have to be upon
understanding you need to know what
you're doing and then the Sheikh he says
because
the person of knowledge Can Do attacking
and can do defending he can do both you
have to be in that position defending
meaning that you will defend any doubts
or sugar someone comes up and he tries
to put forward against Islam when he's
speaking to you right and attacking
means that you will put forward the
message in a strong
eloquent way that where you engage and
give the people the message right so you
have to be able to do these two things
if you're not able to to do these two
things you cannot do proper Dao right
and you cannot do those two things
without knowledge not just it's
literally your whip it it's your shield
and and sword if you have no shield on
sword you cannot fight you know you're
not going to be able to engage with the
people so then the Sheikh says what
happens is that you will get that done
to you wow this is what will happen
right you will get those people with the
Shibu hat instead of you inviting them
to Islam they will take you away from
Islam
and and then the Sheikh says something
very important as well he says that you
are a representation there of Islam so
when and he gives an example if someone
stands in a public place and someone
asks them a question about Islam and
then he's silent he's not able to answer
the doubt how does that look for the
image of the religion how does that look
for the image of Islamic he says that
looks like the religion is being
defeated while in reality it's just an
ignorant person standing who's not able
to convey or answer these questions
right and then the Sheikh mentions
something important as well to keep in
mind
because we don't want to discourage the
people Sheikh mentions and he says that
that doesn't mean
that you don't do that when you're
seeking knowledge
that's a very important thing to keep in
mind yeah because then people they lose
the balance they say that look I'm gonna
do the dawah sorry I'm only gonna do
that one again on the knowledge so now
I'm focusing on knowledge I'm not going
to do that no no you can do both but the
Sheikh says what you will preach when
you are learning and doing that what you
can teach is only what you learn
you stay at what you learned if you
learn something you stop there that's
what you do basically all right
yeah that's what the Sheikh advises and
he finishes by another thing is that you
need to have two things the knowledge
and the Deeds you need to combine
between the knowledge and the actions so
you cannot be just a person who believes
and say to the people
you don't need the Quran yourself right
yeah so that would be like a general
overview I would say that's a beautiful
point and I'm glad he made the
distinction because I find a lot of
people
and I think unfortunately it's only
natural for human beings to want to do
this but whenever they don't know
especially if they're in a public sphere
they kind of make up an answer or just
say what makes the most sense to them at
the time and then yani's unfortunately
sometimes what comes out is is very very
Incorrect and uh may Allah forgive us
and protect us from this but I mean I
think the best approach would just be
okay you know that's an interesting
point personally I've not looked into it
as an individual I have not looked into
it let me go back and find an answer let
me go ask those who do know and I'll
come back and bring you an answer I
think that's the most respectable thing
that can be done in that moment and and
the question is this if I were to say
this to someone who's not Muslim
what is the worst thing they could say
back to me
it's a great you cannot say anything all
they can do is they say okay I respect
that they will respect they have to
respect you you've stated that look this
is not my field of knowledge the problem
people are afraid to look bad but in
reality you will be look good because
they will respect you that you stop and
what you you know you only say what you
know and there is there's never gonna be
any bad response that you would receive
if you say that yeah amazing amazing
absolutely especially since Yani you're
supposed to look the religion you're
sorry you're supposed to make the
religion look good you know imagine
you're focused on making yourself look
good now Islam looks bad because you're
trying to show off or whatever may Allah
forgive us man I mean I mean yeah but I
mean and we do get subhanallah a lot of
people on that table unfortunately
because of that
they come with questions and then they
say like Islam says this I say no Islam
doesn't say this he says no but I'm a
Muslim foreign
they've gone they already think they
know about Islam
and the reason they do is because they
got it from a Muslim they learned it
from so it's not the fault to be honest
because they trusted you as a Muslim and
they thought that you'll be telling them
the truth so then when I tell them that
no this is not correct
it gets surprised okay why did my Muslim
friend say this to me then I just say to
them bring him with you next time you
know but generally the subhanallah this
is what happens people just say whatever
it is and
they just want to speak the passion is
there but technology is not there yeah
interesting
absolutely so what would be your
response to those that come for the sole
intention of trolling or wasting time
that's a great question right so I would
say subhanallah it depends as well on I
wouldn't like deal with everyone the
same way so some people
I will give everyone a chance that's
what I would say so I'll give everyone a
chance in the beginning in the initial
stage and then when you do the hour for
a long time you're instantly able to
tell
whether president sincere or not
and what I say to the people generally
what the most important thing I learned
in that what I've done is that there is
only two types of people since you're an
instance here there is no fair category
so if you're speaking with someone it's
either he's there to waste your time
he's not sincere he's not looking for
the truth it doesn't matter what you
throw in his face he's not going to
accept it and you've got a sincere
person who's genuinely curious right so
when someone comes to you on the dawa
table
it all depends on their behavior how
they start off how they behave in the
beginning you will have to judge based
on the apparent right so if he behaves
in a certain way you respond based on
the behavior that he would show you
right and then you will take it from
there you will see is that person just
there to waste my time if he's there to
waste my time then it's an obligation on
you as a Muslim not to engage with him
you would say to him sorry but I can
engage with you I can't talk to you why
Allah teaches that in the Quran is
that if you hear the verses of Allah be
mocked being disrespected right Do not
sit with them and tell they speak about
something else and then Allah says that
you are like them if you sit with them
why are you like them because if I'm
sitting in a setting and people are
mocking let's say brother rum here he's
very handsome so they're not gonna come
okay right but let's say for example
they your monkey brother around me and
I'm sitting there I'm not speaking
there is a form of me agreeing with what
they're doing right or wrong I'm
agreeing with it I'm accepting it
because if I do actually care I would
say no no he didn't don't talk about him
behind his back don't say this about him
so if I'm sitting in a setting in which
people are mocking Allah uh and The
Messengers I'm not speaking I'm a part
of it I'm like them there's no
difference in the Sin that's why it
means the verse that you all have the
same sin as them
you'll have the same it's not a joke
you're sitting on they're making Allah
on the messenger so you will have to
basically from your experience in dawa
you'll engage with the initial stage
you'll deal with them based on their
apparent and then in the end you will
decide whether they're worthy of your
engagement or not they're not worthy
you're not going to engage with them you
weigh the harms and the benefit this is
always what you need to do as a day is
there more harms is there more benefits
where are the harms and the benefits are
and then that's why you need wisdom in
the tower without wisdom you shouldn't
be doing that 100 100 and this kind of
leads into my next question which would
be
what are some of the things you've
learned over the years because wisdom is
yeah it's not something that's on or off
it's something that you gain in
different categories over time
especially with Islam so it probably
takes you know a good amount of
experience and understanding of people
and good reading of people to be able to
determine okay this person's completely
you know insincere or not willing to
listen or to the best of my judgment you
know I shouldn't speak with them versus
someone who is Sincere but maybe is a
little rough around the edges or
something so what are some of the things
you've learned over the years and have
you developed you know a wisdom for the
devil over time
okay so there is there is a technical
definition of of the word wisdom in
Islam which is
wisdom is putting everything in its
place and in the right time saying the
right thing in the right time right or
doing the right thing in the right time
right this is the the general definition
of wisdom right and then you've got the
definition of his wisdom which will
Encompass the Quran
and we need to keep that in mind now if
we got those two things together we got
everything right the Dao is perfect
because if you're putting the right
answers in the right time behaving in
the right way in the right time through
the wisdom which is the Quran that's it
what else do you need you've got the
perfect now behavior that you could
possibly do right so Allah says in the
Quran is a beautiful verse Allah says
he gives wisdom to whoever who he Wills
when you tell him
whoever is given wisdom he is given
abundant good
so Allah chooses whom he gives the
wisdom and wisdom here can mean the
Islamic knowledge so it's Allah Prophet
saws if Allah loves someone he gives him
knowledge and religion right so Allah
chooses certain people to give in
bestow upon them knowledge bestow upon
them wisdom right but in general this is
the idea of wisdom is behaving in the
right way in the right time dealing with
things in the right way in the right
time saying the right thing in the right
time I might have the information but
that person might not be ready to listen
to it he might but not be ready for me
to tell it to him that way now the
question is how do you understand that
it is what I think most people
unfortunately doing dawah in the west
are missing which is to be connected
with dilemma
to be connected to Dollar if you really
want to know how to deal with certain
situations if you really want to know
where to gain wisdom and what wisdom is
and how wisdom is implemented you have
to sit under Scholars because they will
teach you is before all of what we
talked about manners comes first
if your is not there it doesn't matter
what you spout out of your mouth
it will look filthy even if it's good
because of how you behave of how you
speak of how you engage with the people
right so I would say dawa is 95 manners
even if someone is a complete Islam
hater and you just behave with him in a
very nice way nice Manner and just say
I'm I'm not going to engage with you I
apologize I don't I don't have time I
apologize but you you know you've been
very aggressive so if it's okay I'm not
going to engage with you he is Gonna
Leave knowing that he's defeated
because look he didn't get what he want
he wanted to get a reaction from you he
ended up leaving with nothing
the people who will leave after engaging
with you with good manners are always
going to live with a good impression
about Islam and this is what we want our
goal is to do dawa which is to say to
talk to the people of Islam right which
means we want the people to live with a
good impression about this religion
that's what we want so manners comes
first okay and this is you have to sit
under the scholars in order for you to
gain the manners to understand what is
the best way to deal with things they
will teach you you know there's times
where my I got beaten up by a scholar
there's no problem
sometimes but yeah you need to be taught
certain things right for example
something so simple like I was sitting
in with one of my teachers for example
right we're all sitting down I was young
at that time
say let's say I was 19 or something like
that and I and then you've got people
sitting there you've got the older
people they put chair a chair
so I come and I put a chair and I sit
down
so then the Sheikh he said to me why are
you sitting down
why are you something as simple as that
you're young you're 19 years old you
should sit in your feet
you shouldn't be sitting on a chair okay
that old person who's 60 70 or you can't
say it on the chair he's he's got a
problem but you why are you sitting so
relaxed in a in in some in a in a
gathering of knowledge in which you need
to have haiba knowledge needs to have
its respect and honor
needs to have another individual but
knowledge has to have the atmosphere of
respect and honor if you're sitting in a
setting of knowledge you're not sitting
playing games you cannot be looking left
and right and playing you have to be 100
focused and this is
right so this these kind of things you
cannot pick up from books
you cannot pick up from books that's why
the PO he said
the amateurs they think the books can
lead someone to understand the Sciences
but they don't
right you cannot just by reading a book
understand how to implement the
knowledge and that Loom and you cannot
be guided into real understanding
without the is
we all know this Hadith we hear about
this the the scholars are the
inheritance of the prophets they are the
connection they are the people who
inherited the knowledge from the prophet
salallahu
if I want a part of the inheritance
there is only one way to get it which is
through the scholars
it's not through the books it's through
so you need to connect as much as you
can with dilemma you need to listen to
them gain knowledge from them
understanding from them and through them
you'll understand because you will see
how they answer questions
you will see how they deal with the
people
he was the best teacher who was a better
teacher than him when a man came to him
his fasting and he said sorry can I kick
can I kiss my my wife when I'm fasting
he said to him no and the other person
came he said to him yes and then we
understand from that that you give one
answer to one person you give another
Essence based on his situation one has a
strong desire the other person can
control his desire
so because he can control his desire he
can kiss his wife on his fasting there's
no problem it's not going to go forward
the other person he can't
so it's two different answers to the
same question so this is given that I
answered in the right time based on the
situation right and we learned that the
best from the prophet sallallahu
that is I think that is very beautifully
put and I think it's kind of
multifaceted because I I've tried to
read you know some of these some of the
books whether it be like
Hadith or yeah a lot of this stuff not
only is it confusing but you open up the
doors for your for yourself to confuse
yourself about it you know to not
understand it you think it means one
thing but it means something completely
different so not only not only is there
the aspect uh but you you very
beautifully explained which is the
wisdom and how you explain things to
people and and exactly how much you give
them right it's kind of like baking
sometimes you don't want to put too much
salt you don't want to put too much
sugar kind of thing right but there's
also you yourself misunderstanding
what's in the books because how do you
even know you have the capacity to
really understand it so I think the
points you made bro are are beautiful
and I actually wanted to play a clip for
us and for the audience uh just 60
seconds of you giving dawa to the
brother now I won't spoil anything
before I put it up my heart
want exploded but also melted when I saw
this video but I think it's all the
people understand once I put it up while
I'm grabbing it do any of the brothers
want to jump in quickly yes there's two
quick super chats that I didn't want to
address but I think I know has a point
yeah I wanted to ask you brother if what
if someone does not have access to them
what do they live in an area where they
just don't have that access
[Music]
um
then that's a very excellent question
and it's an issue in the west it's a
huge issue in the west as a is in
comparison to some countries where you
have Islam right
first we've got one option called Hijra
right that option is available for
anyone to do permissible it's very
recommended if you're going to seek
knowledge so that is that is one option
that I would say to people who are
serious about seeking knowledge
is that you do Hijra and you set under
the feet of the scores of the feet of
development right just like you see
people for Dunya purposes they leave
their countries
women girls little girls go without
countries to learn about Dunya
right and the parents let them go for
Donia purposes so the Deen is the most
important thing it is more worthy of a
person traveling to a different country
and sitting down and learning it has to
be taken seriously right so I would say
the best method I would say there's no
doubt is to go sit down under the
scholars learn the language and
understand the religion the best way
this is the my the most recommended
option I would give right which is the
hedger right second thing is to try your
best to connect to the students of
knowledge and students of knowledge in
the west who connect are connected to
the scholars
that's the best second thing you can do
so you've got certain people in the west
they are well known to be connected to
Scholars they travel to they translate
videos to the scholars they travel to
Medina to Mecca to Yemen to Egypt
wherever they travel and they always
engage with they have the numbers if
there is any queers they can engage with
them right so that's the best second
thing you can do is to be around those
students of knowledge gain knowledge
from them learn from them and and then
uh online try to learn as much as you
can from the scholars that's that's what
you can do right but nothing is equal to
sitting down and learning this is the
truth nothing is going to be like that
right so even bukharis
in his book
right he put a chapter and he said the
virtue of the person present over the
person who is not present in the setting
of knowledge they're not equal
the ending of the reading he said uh he
closed all of the he said we're not
going to do best we're not going to do
this online it's going to be only for
the people who are present
because the people who are prison are
not equal to the people who are not
present they need to give to be given
more virtue because they came here they
sat down and they learned the knowledge
right today we're very lazy we want to
do zoom zoom everything you know just
zoom this meeting no no we have to sit
down because in Zoom I cannot teach you
or I can teach you when you're sitting
in front of me
um wow
I got two questions all right so the
first one is in regards to the unama
like what can you best find these
Scholars is there a specific country
that you're referring to no that would
amount are there's a lot of elements in
different countries right so you've got
our element which are not controversial
and you've got rlma which you might find
someone who's got issues with them my
advice is always to stay away from
controversial people in general right
that's what I advise people to do
someone is very controversial they just
don't be wasting your time listening to
it just stick with the people who are
avoiding controversy focusing on the
Deen of Allah most before they they just
bickering and fighting with other people
right but if God you've got a very well
known recognized people and and you've
got people in different countries it
depends on the country right so we've
got our in for example
in in uh
in Mauritania and his book held by n
it's a b it's he's one of the biggest
that we we recently had right so I mean
for example he used to memorize a
thousand line of poetry from every
science
he used to memorize the full dictionary
of listen
you know volumes right is the one of the
most voluminous dictionaries which used
to memorize all of it he used to
memorize the full-time serial of a
falcon
right and he used to just recollect it
to this memory with his teaching in
series and the Sheikh is just 50 years
ago or something I'm not talking about
someone like a 15 for 500 years before
I'm talking about some reason he died
recently right so it just depends on the
region or and where you search uh
uh in in Yemen it's very well known very
well known scholar who is a Mahadev
who's a big muhadist in
egypti Arabia it depends on in the
country right
recently it was one of the biggest
teachers probably is we're so we're too
distant from
that's why you don't think they're there
but there are many there are many and
there are many teachers and there are
many very some of them Allah
some of the dreams I have is just to sit
with them that's it just sit down and
listen that's it nothing else I don't
want anything else right so one of my
favorite today
uh and I would say in Saudi Arabia
specifically
this is one of my favorite Scholars
today and alongside when it comes to
Akita issues uh
yeah so those two are very very like
their their levels are higher than a lot
of other people right if when it comes
to to the level of knowledge and
understanding and memorization of the
religion and eloquence of speech and how
to deal in wisdom and all of that
they've got things about them that you a
lot of people don't have
um
in Morocco it's very very beautiful a
lot of knowledge you can get from
community
and obviously some people have got some
issues with him you've got those people
who've got issues with every scholar out
there you know but generally yeah
this this begs the question that like
how do we not interrupt you but how do
we know how to discern the good Scholars
from the ones that are slightly deviant
or preaching something that isn't
correct Akita or something like that for
a Layman because for someone with a
little bit more foundational knowledge
they will be able to tell what is who
but most vast majority of people they
might not be able to
yeah
okay there's a few things there first
thing I would say you cannot tell
anything unless you gain knowledge first
right when you are a jail
you cannot how if you are a jail
yourself if you're ignorant how can you
tell who is knowledge
yeah you first you have to get my
knowledge and then through the knowledge
you can distinguish between the
knowledgeable and ignorant so if you ask
an alignment to determine they cannot do
it that's the answer right what a Layman
can do is first is what the most
important thing he does Dua to Allah to
guide them to the correcting the
strength right the second thing that
Layman does is that he understands
only with the Quran Sunnah
and I want you to keep that very very
important point of mind if you see
someone says my opinion I think this is
this this is that this is and you don't
hear him saying the prophet saws said
does not consider the island from our
perspective he's not a scholar Allah
it is clear verses in the hearts of
those people of knowledge
Allah
are the scholars you've got those people
who fear Allah they got a combination
between they always say and their
apparent is prayer and worshiping Allah
so they're combining these two things
right so whenever they speak they say
Allah messenger said
those are the people look I challenge
anyone today for example to find one
video One lecture he doesn't say Allah
one lecture I'll give you in what you
want you know find one lecture where he
does not mention Quran
right and I would say repeatedly not
once or twice repeatedly you will see
the Sheikh every couple of words is
Prophet salallahu said uh then he goes
to the sahaba um
right step by step then then he says
then he goes to the next level and they
will see them quoting those self that we
we talk about the self are not just
something we we say self no self is to
actually listen and learn what they said
you have in you in your memory what they
how they used to view the Dunya how they
used to view the knowledge that they had
you have it in your memory and you quote
them when you speak
this is the person that is a person of
knowledge right so what you do is you
look for the island because Allah
as the people of dick and Victorious
so the people that Allah commands you to
ask are the people of the Quran and Sun
the people who will say Allah said and
the messenger said when you ask him can
I do this he says to you yes because the
prophet saws or Allah
right and you go you find the person you
trust you see his most knowledgeable
trusted he's not controversial as I said
second the person is not an a
controversial individual right third
he's only speaking using the Quran and
Sunnah and you can see if of his
righteousness his righteousness is
outward is apparent to the people right
this is a general criteria for you to
follow and listen to someone
those who struggle for us will guide
them our ways don't think that Allah
will leave you lost it doesn't exist
it's impossible if you make Dua to Allah
if you're sincere if you look Allah will
connect you with the right people you
will bestow upon you the blessing of
connecting you and the people that you
need to listen to and learn from right
our issue is we want to listen to the
controversial people yeah because they
are the ones who get drugs
if you're a scholar you don't get clicks
you know if you're controversial you get
clicks if you're fighting on this
brother and the brother is fighting the
brother he's refuting this person is
refuting you want to click on that the
people are the problem they want to
click in that they want to watch that
they're not valuing the knowledge yeah
and you've got Aruna Rashid you've got
Imam Malik
when he said to him come
he said to Imam Malik and I want you to
listen about the cartoon Rashid is from
the from the lineage of the prophet
salallahu
he was Muslim he was the Khalifa
um
if you put it in in this term he was the
highest status person on Earth at the
time for Muslims
right
and then he said to Imam Malik come and
read motha for me
do you know what Imam Alexander
he said
I have not read al-motta senso and so
meaning people come read on me I don't
go reading people yeah people come and
they read them
right so then he The Next Step he said
to him he needs to come to the mosque
sorry
she said to him let's go do it in the
mosque
sorry no apology he said come do it in
my presence
so come
so I can hear the Mota in my presence so
then in mathematics it's something very
important he said this knowledge cannot
be only for the elites
it has to be for everyone
so you have to do in the mosque
so then Haru Rashid had to go to IBN
Malik to listen
and he's I'm telling you the high status
person on earth right the prophet Islam
said you have to obey your uh
he's the righteous person from the the
linge of the Prophet salallahu but he
still told him that why did him Alex
Imam Malik say that an ignorant person
would say that's arrogant but and a
person who understands a person of
knowledge will say he is given you the
value of knowledge
nothing surpasses knowledge knowledge
has a value above everything else it
doesn't it doesn't matter who you are
you have to humble yourself for the dean
of Allah
this is the mentality that we need all
need to have with the dean of Allah
so brother at one point you will mention
the thing about presence and you were
saying there was a difference between
someone who's sitting and listening to
knowledge who's President who's not
president but how does one actually be
more present in these situations because
I know a lot of people have difficulties
when it comes to this
it will come back to what we said in the
beginning uh anyways right it's the idea
of second knowledge is that through the
Hijra or being with the students of
knowledge so you have to be present in
the Gatherings of knowledge there's only
two ways either you travel to the
Gathering of knowledge
I mean like mentally
mentally present like sitting down
okay how to be mentally present this is
something you have to train your naps to
do
you have to train you enough to do it's
not something that will come one day you
go
you push away every distraction out
there that's why the problem some people
want to learn about Islam they do it on
their phone watching a lecture and then
notification okay let me check this
WhatsApp message okay let me check this
tweet let me retweet this and then you
come back to the video go back and
there's no benefit
from it right if you want to focus on
something you have to give 100
reflection towards that thing
nothing else you focus on that thing
right and you bring as the self used to
say you bring your your weapons which is
the pen and paper
we don't just listen you have to write
down the important information
you have to put effort you have to read
and revise read and revise push yourself
to be sitting down there listening if
you feel like you're you're getting
dizzy you you wake up yourself you focus
right
seeking knowledge is not a like taking a
nap you have to put effort
that's why the people of knowledge are
not equal to the people who don't have
knowledge
they reflect on this
the people of knowledge are not equal to
the people of no knowledge so in order
for you to gain knowledge you will have
to put effort Abdullah is a beautiful
example
he used to be young and he used to go
seek knowledge listen to the to the
sahaba and learn from the sahaba right
and then the other youngsters because
was very young he said to him come let's
play he said no no and he used to go and
he used to see college and he used to go
knock on the doors and then the people
say to him oh oh cousin of the prophet
of Allah don't you just tell me I will
come to you you are the cousin of the
Prophet I will come teach you you don't
have to come all the way to my door he
said no and he used to come and seek
knowledge then that same person that
said to him come let us do something
else let us play he said I saw everyone
around best learning later on
older in age after he got that knowledge
that he was spending when he was young
for leaving playing and messing around
and wasting time on video games and all
of the stuff right when he focused on
seeking knowledge he ended up being the
P the person that people come to to seek
knowledge right so it is that trying to
put as much Focus as you can and Allah I
don't forget that I'll always mention
that is very important Allah is the one
who shows us the guidance we don't we
just need to ask Allah if we have
sincere intention we put the effort you
can do anything you put your mind
in the color
do you have any practical secrets for
making Dua aside from tahajud
the main important thing is to avoid the
The Miner where the things that prevents
your diet from being accepted like for
instance the eating Haram right cutting
the thighs of uh family
these things can be sense in general can
be a means for your Dua not to be
not to be accepted right so you have to
stay away from from sins as much as you
can as much as possible uh obviously
anyone is going to be perfect but
avoiding those main sins that prevent
your diet from being accepted and then
also keep your in mind that you need to
have an attentive heart when you're
making because of the Hadith Allah does
not accept
distracted heart
if your heart is distracted when you're
making
then Allah does not going to accept that
type of you go your mind is somewhere
else and you just say words yeah you
have to be very attentive and do Dua in
the last third of the night
it is the time where Allah descends
specifically to answer your call
Allah himself the lord of the alamin the
lord of the world comes down and he says
o my servant
ask me I will give you request for me I
will give you what else do you want
subhanallah we need to understand that
last third and you have Ramadan today
you know the last third of the night and
understand that Allah like the prophet
saws told us Allah will accept your Dua
as long as you're not hasty
your Dua is accepted in different forms
first he can let's say you ask for money
the money can be delayed
it's not coming instantly it can come
after 10 years 20 years because it's not
good for you today Allah knows what's
good for you and he will give it to you
and he thinks it's good for you right
you do I might be delayed to the
afterlife it might raise your status in
Paradise or it might be a means for you
to for your sins to be elevated
so do I can be accepted in different
ways it's not necessarily that what you
ask for you get because Allah you might
love something and it is bad for you and
you might hate something that is good
for you Allah
knows and you do not know
Allah knows and we do not know so if
Allah doesn't give me something Allah
wants good for me if he didn't give it
to me then that thing is not really good
for me
so I think brother Rami has a video
pulled up I don't want to go on too long
of a tension but I just had a question
right now so I gotta ask you
um generally I'm not looking for a photo
but a lot of brothers that live in the
west you spoke about you know expiating
sins or removing sins for dwells to not
be rejected and a lot of brothers are
unfortunately eating harami and they
think that it's not pork but it's okay
you can say Bismillah we live in a
Christian country so you know if you
live in a Christian country like you
know America Canada UK then we can eat
chicken and beef that's not allowed
certified or you don't have to check so
what are your views on that
well first we we disagree with this
terminology of saying this is a
Christian country according to the last
sentence in the UK questions are less
than 50 of the population and those
Christians that are less than 50 of the
population in the UK are not really
Christians they don't go to the church
and believe in their book it's just a
form that you get when you get home they
just click Christian you know because
they're born in a Christian Society so
they don't really believe in
Christianity right so when first we
disagree that with this idea this is a
Christian Tamil right number two let's
take the assumption that it is a
Christian country let's say okay it is a
Christian country even if you're a
Muslim if you do not Slaughter the meat
and you electrocute it it's hard for you
to eat even from a Muslim it doesn't
matter it's a Christian country or not
if the meat is not slaughtered it is not
Halal it's Mehta Allah explicitly says
in the Quran chapter 5 verse three
so Allah mentions the different types of
meat
and this method is dead meat that you're
eating it's Haram even if a Muslim is
the one who electrocuted the meat even
if he mentions the name of Allah it
doesn't matter the meat has you need to
do the care of the meat you need to
actually slaughter them slaughter them
and today they don't do this
so whether we accept even if you want to
lie and say it's a Christian country
it's not a Christian country they do not
Slaughter the meat and therefore you're
eating atheist meat right there is is
being electrocuted and it is not good
for you yeah I mean Allah what's good
for you the one good for yourself you're
eating meat till the body remains and
the blood remains on the body after the
death and all of the germs and the
bacteria and everything remains in the
world and you're eating damage which is
unhealthy for you Allah is making
something healthy and good for you and
you're avoiding it to eat from something
which is Haram right and the prophet
Islam he said the person raises his
hands
his clothing is Haram he's eating is
Haram he's drinking
how does he expect Allah to answer his
God if you're eating Haram how do you
expect Allah to answer
the Dua that you're making right so they
are in countries like here in the UK
there are very good organizations like
for example HMC
halal meat certificate HMC here in the
UK the very they are very uh they do
very very extensive checks
very diligent one and they make sure
that actually it's slaughtered and it's
weekly and they make sure this is being
slaughtered in Islamic you can eat from
that it's more expensive so people tend
to buy from other meats right they don't
want to buy this one they buy from other
ones but it is there and you can eat
halal meat in the UK there's no problem
right but eating the other types of meat
that are doubtable and this and that you
know in in a country like the UK today
or these countries that are no longer
yeah it is meat right and these
countries these countries are no longer
Christian countries to begin with it's
an excuse that people make to eat at
McDonald's you know right and let alone
what the ramifications are on a
spiritual level that we that's in the
Unseen we're not even aware of that
absolutely absolutely yes
why are you not eating Allah is asking
from Allah Allah's name was and he's
dated detailed to you that which is
Haram to avoid right and then Allah says
the the awliyah of the shayateen they
try to entice you from eating Haram they
try to push you into it you know they
try to stop you from eating the meat
that is permissible that is the Allah
has given you that you can eat and
subhanallah when when Surah the verse
that I mentioned
when when Allah mentioned the things are
Haram because they were asking what
types of things the next verse then it
says what is
they ask you what was made Halal for
them so then Allah says everything good
is mithala
Allah stop you from some things that you
need to avoid so Allah the goods are
many the Halal is a lot but people focus
on that which Allah made impermissible
yeah beautiful
yeah that's a very beautiful point you
want to play the video yeah yeah
inshallah that's a very good point a lot
of people it's upon a lot they they want
to focus on things they can't have and I
think that's that's almost something
that's almost a liberalistic principle
you know go for what you want and a lot
of the time people want what they can't
have so yeah they're they're really
really enticed to uh to want to do uh
things Allah prohibited but yeah it goes
back to what you said it's really about
one sincerity and two it's about
knowledge it's about knowing and
understanding why you're going to obey
this command it's not just that you have
to not eat meat because that's it you
just don't it's because the most
knowledgeable the most wise the most
high the one who created you and the me
in the universe and everything in it has
told you not to eat it and it doesn't
say anything uh except that it's it's
what's best for us as you mentioned
before so I think that's a very
beautiful point but with that being said
inshallah I do have the video I'm going
to pull it up right now
is for men and women I don't know where
you get this idea of women he's a
punishment that applies to men and women
can you tell me the dangers of adultery
when families are wrecked what happens
when children become dysfunctional
crimes killing raping stealing men so
adultery will result in a cycle of
killing majority of criminals come from
single parent homes in the west there's
a book called The Boy Christ and by
Warren Pharaoh it has all of the stats
that I'm telling adultery makes single
parent Homes single parent homes causes
crimes and killings Islam makes a law
that prohibits adultery which by one
life saving thousands of lives thousands
of destructions thousands of problems
happening in society by making that law
which you say you disagree with well you
know what I agree with you now you see
it made me change no problem
okay no problem
and I wish they had it here
the guy in the beginning came with a
normal misconception and he left saying
we need Sharia Allah we should have it
here subhanallah uh my first question is
how the heck did you do that like what
was that Allah he surprised
because I was asking him
well it's it's when the wisdom of Allah
is presented to the people
any sincere individual has no choice but
to accept right when the the Heckman the
wisdom the ultimate wisdom of Allah
especially for people that have seen the
opposite because he is the type of
people uh he's one of the people who've
seen the opposite in his country he's
he's seen when that law is not applied
what do you have
so I don't need to convince him that if
you don't do that that would be bad
because he's already seen the opposite
right so have the half of the job is
done already all I need to do is to
explain the wisdoms behind that specific
act that Allah says that we should do
and why it is Ultimate wisdom and again
it comes back to the idea they tell us
about these issues they tell us that
Allah when he commands the killing of
our life it is to save hundreds of lives
in return
it is not to kill that life or to end
that life but it is to save other lives
in return in the end right so when
people put that mind and put that
Concept in their mind and understand it
fully then The Message of Islam is there
is nothing more beautiful than it you
know and we need to to be we need to
ourselves understand these things
so we don't become uh apologetic quote
unquote and try to twist the religion
and change the teachings in order for us
to appease and please these people when
they come to us with these types of
misconceptions we need to be able as we
said to have the defensive was talking
about is to explain to clear clarify the
hat and these people had I'll tell you
something there is no sugar that someone
can come with except that you can use as
evidence for Islam
now keep that in mind there is no doubt
or a criticism someone can bring against
Islam except that you can use that same
thing to show how Islam is unique how
Islam is beautiful how Islam is from God
right you just need to know how to use
it which way you need to use it
[Music]
well yeah subhanallah I mean that that
clip I think there's a lot going on
there so there is I think um a level of
understanding of who this person is what
he's been through like you mentioned
it's all around him and he seemed to be
very aware actually because when you ask
the question I think that's what's
really important that we we look to
understand each individual as an
individual you ask them a question he
didn't just give a cookie cutter answer
he said what happens he said oh it
wrecks families that's the first box
checked okay what happens with family
direct you walked him down that path and
I think that's so beautiful
um all while you know having good
manners there are people out there that
Yanni they might have done it in an
arrogant way you know like look your
people look what happened to your people
you know that's instantly distinguishing
yourself from them in a way that Yani is
putting them bad and try it almost
seeming arrogant so
how important
is is mannerisms and more specifically
what mannerisms can you point out that
make a big difference with dawa
okay
so I I gave like this this I listen as
well I was given this lecture for the
people or my charity of how to do that
or this and that and I mentioned to them
something very important the first thing
you need to do in the dollar I said is
you need to do what I called what I
labeled for them is you need to do a
diagnosis
someone is coming to you with a disease
it's not a medical disease it's a heart
disease if he's not a Muslim he's got a
disease straight up if he's Muslim
struggling with senses God disease and
Sr right so people are coming to you
with diseases as a dad you need to be
able to diagnose the person based on the
diagnosis your approach comes
the the problem is some people have this
programmatic approach with everyone no
based on the person based on diagnosing
him based on seeing how someone who's
not a PhD holder I don't need to start
giving him philosophical jargon for no
reason
confusing the guy he doesn't even know
what I'm talking about in the discussion
he just left confused right we need to
see who we're dealing with and we need
to speak to them based on the level of
understanding okay so the first thing
let's say in the mannerisms is
understanding the person in front of us
a bit of empathy is needed right empathy
is necessary you need to put yourself in
the shoes you need to put yourself in
the position if they're coming asking
you a question that you might get
offended by first you need to understand
in your mind that he didn't live like
you he delivers a Muslim he's not born
as a Muslim he didn't have people
answering his question he's born in a
society in which taught him that this is
the reality based on that you put
yourself in his shoes you have empathy
right second thing is I would say is the
most important thing
listen more than you talk
unless unless you are invited to talk
which means that the other person wants
to listen
so if the other person is not you don't
see that he wants to ask a question if
you see any movement that he wants to
speak you stop straight away let him
speak doesn't matter what you're saying
stop keep the idea and then speak after
he puts his point forward because he
will
you will make him comfortable you will
make him put his guard down you will
make him understand that you are here
sincerely caring about him you don't you
don't just want to push this down my
throat like some religions do and then
live
so it's very important very necessary to
listen more than you talk to listen a
lot to attentively listen I'm not just
saying yeah shake your head and then you
just you know actually understand what
the person is saying right so
attentively listen never get angry
never get angry never become upset
and never retaliate with bad words or
evil evil manners never do that if
you're patient you listen you diagnose
the person and you've got what you call
the pre the the things that are
necessary for giving we said in the
beginning of this podcast you should be
fine
well I don't think you need anything
else yeah any questions
if you okay you said the diagnose but
how can one properly diagnose someone
who's coming to them
if they're too excited
you or that I'll be honest
the person is excited
he's too excited
yes and that's a fantastic news
yes so so that would mean you need to
put yourself in a column composed
position in order for you to look you
need to have a grip over your emotions
if you're going to do that
so I said you cannot get angry that your
emotions must be in your control I'm not
saying don't feel them I'm saying you
don't display them there's a difference
between the two I you can be offended
but you cannot display the yourself
being offended to the people cannot you
might get angry by an action you cannot
display that to the people you have to
learn to suppress those types of
emotions Allah when he spoke about
it's a way of like suppressing life
which is like serious anger they is
suppressing it
and those who pardon the people right
Allah loves the Mycenaean right you have
to be like that you have to have this
level of self-control so you're excited
don't let your excitement ruin your
mission
you're excited because you want to do
good you cannot make the excitement ruin
the goal that you want to do which is to
invite them to Islam
try to and look the more that way you do
the more you will get this idea of as
you said the diagnosis as well it's very
important you need to ask questions in
order for you to diagnose
through asking questions through
listening that's why I say listening is
very important because through someone's
words you can learn a lot about them
through other person says you can learn
a lot about them right so all you need
to do is to listen listen listen listen
and you need to engage with the people
in a respectful Manner and you need to
suppress your own kind of emotions you
don't just display them in in their way
and by the way look the face tells it
all right so you might be angry
suppressing here by your face is like
you want to eat the best that's not what
we want you know you have to keep the
right Expressions where people don't
actually like feel like intimidated by
you
okay another question
when you're giving though
and let's say you've got your emotions
in check and let's see you're diagnosing
them how do you know when to stop how do
you know when enough is enough and you
have to pull back now and stop giving
them or else it's just going to overload
them okay I'll give you two easy points
two easy ways one when person when
person denies observable realities I'll
give an example when I say to someone
okay this is a building and he says no
no this is not a building
we go we come to this I come to this
level all the time you'd be surprised
many people do you I don't exist you
don't exist the table there's nothing
exists nothing you you when you come to
this level in which Things Are
very basic and they are rejecting it
then okay that's a red flag you know
straight away that person is not really
engaging or intellectually number two
when they are repeatedly contradicting
themselves
they say something
after a few minutes they come and they
contradict what they said
which means now they're arguing for the
sake of arguing so they're not noticing
what positions they're putting for
because they're not thinking about them
they're just throwing it at you because
they're arguing with you so you just
throw whatever comes in their mind and
therefore they will always contradict
themselves so when you start in your
mind pointing out the contradictions
that he said don't do this and two
minutes later he said but other people
are doing this you get what I'm trying
to say you start to see these repeated
contradictions they know okay that
person is arguing for the sake of
arguing this is not there's no longer a
time for me to I'm not going to waste my
time anymore there you go this is a pack
for you thank you for your time but what
if it's neither of the two what if
they're just listening to you and you're
just like yeah like this this guy is
taking it like let me give him some more
let me give him some more how do you
know when to stop I I I don't think this
will ever happen if someone is not
sincere
he cannot listen
it's impossible if I'm coming and I'm
not sincere I cannot just let you speak
speak about something that I don't like
I don't care about I don't want to hear
about this is torture for him you know
if he doesn't want it doesn't like it
doesn't want to hear about it and you
keep talking about it Allah created and
he said the messenger and he's silent
he's listening that means he's got an
interest in listening to to your what
you want to say right unless there's
other signs like a person is of a
specific group that you know that those
people are extreme Christians that they
always try to come waste your time then
you ignore them but general public
they're not going to listen to you
because look time is valuable and we as
human beings we value our time we don't
sit down and listen for long periods of
time to something about something to
listen to something that we don't care
about especially with the time uh span
and the time attention span that we have
today because of the generation they're
not gonna sit down and listen to you
trust me no one is going to sit down and
listen to hear about something you don't
like they don't want to hear about just
to waste your time they're not going to
do that and always know you're rewarded
you judge the apparent so if the
apparent is good you continue to speak
because every word you say Allah is
rewarding you for you getting your job
done the goal is not the shahada the
goal is delivering the message
so let's let's address these uh these
four chats uh first one
brother asks assalamualaikum Brothers my
eye itches a lot so I was wondering if I
could use eye drops while fasting
but none of us are shares
bro but you make wudu and you when you
make wudu you have to he can use it he
can use it there's no problem it's not
it's not considered food or drink and
based on that the elements is
permissible to use and also uh they they
use a chaos for this idea as well and
they say that if a person used to make
another he made an oath with Allah I'm
not going to eat or drink and he put an
eye drop does he break his off no
because he didn't eat or drink so based
on that we say that this eye drop is not
considered either drink it does not
break your fast hmm
look at the wisdom look at the wisdom
man here I am trying to like be a smart
not a smart ass but just using my own
Interlake and nah bro no no no not like
this but like use the wisdom there and
you bought like what the scholars were
saying and how they deducted this
reasoning it's beautiful I'm the uh next
from brother wahab I'm the winner salaam
alaikum my dear brothers and sisters
give my Salam to brother Muhammad I
enjoy watching him do his thing alone
about it Miller preserve him we need to
talk one day with this brother he's a
nice brother we organize I organize
something with him inshallah
I don't answer the question
right this is the most common question
that's why I say I I usually don't
answer any personal questions so I I try
to avoid them as much as possible bro
just just say I come from Allah into
Allah will return inshallah yeah I
usually give different answers sometimes
I'm from my mother's womb sometimes from
dust sometimes yeah from Muslims land
you know it depends you know
people know I'm an Arab and that's the
important thing to know that's it that's
enough
bro what is this question man are you
selling beards in merch store did I read
that right
no not selling beards bro just make
dwell to Allah during last third of the
night like the brother said to grow a
beard inshallah it up uh Muhammad speak
to how he has such a good memory quoting
the Bible science books Etc I love you
all for Allah may Allah loving you may
Allah love you for loving us for his
sake Allah I mean but brother Muhammad
um how would he answer that
I would say that muscle is a memory
sorry my memory is a muscle memory is a
muscle just like you go to the gym I'm
sure you guys go to the gym mashallah so
when you go to the gym or you work out
because I work at home I don't work out
in the gym if you work out you've got a
muscle what do you need to do to make
that muscle stronger
you have to keep training right so in
order for you to have good memory you
have to keep memorizing
step by step every day you memorize you
memorize you memorize you revise you
memorize again you revise you memorize
it's not like someone no I don't think
anyone is born with with Perfect Memory
it doesn't have it's a muscle
there is always exercise that's why this
I mentioned to you for example from
Mauritania
you don't have tablets they don't have
phones they don't have laptops it's
their memory that's it they have some
stones that they carve on you understand
that's it no papers even no pins
so they use their memory on a daily
basis and that's why the Arabs had the
strong memory that they had they had to
rely on it as a memory
so this muscle always strengthens the
more you memorize you try to memorize
the Quran you memorize the Hadith
memorize that as I need the names of the
salaf ETC and the more you memorize the
more memorizing next time becomes easier
for you
the more you pick up information quickly
so that's what I would say well the
brother has to go unfortunately you got
to start we all accept you fast and it
was it's me as well in in 10 minutes
Well mine's uh you want to finish up or
are we gonna no no no no no 10 minutes
10 minutes okay my thoughts in like
I think one minute actually yeah yeah in
one minute so he's an hour ahead of you
yeah I listen yes it was a blessed time
I saw a lot bro man I love bless you
may I like that
I mean I mean we can all speak again
soon
so bro you want to put the I show speed
clip and then we got uh three more Super
chats all right all right now let's do
it quickly
so heads up the quality is not the
greatest because uh speed was streaming
at the time but uh we can put up with it
what's that over there
what's this
what
do you want me to comment while you play
or
yeah if I at any point if you want you
can ask me to to pause it um but it's
only three minutes if you want to wait
to the end inshallah it's completely up
okay play it is
what is this though
what is this
I'm speed
yeah
no no no no no no no no I'm not trolling
bro I'm not talking I'm serious bro okay
so are you
are you for me yeah undefod right now
buddy
yeah
yes I do
yes I do I believe in God
okay
like you and me
there are Christians who believe that
God is a man and he died on a cross we
don't believe that we leave the Creator
created everything if I tell you think
about a color that does not resemble any
color in existence
red a color that does not resemble any
color in existence a new color can you
think of a new color yeah like the
blackest grayish
but still you're using using Hazard and
exists black and gray can you think
about a color that does not resemble any
color in existence
right we say Allah
before he does not resemble the creation
all right Allah is not a man or a woman
is not an idol it's not a picture but
he's powerful what
we haven't
a discussion yeah
wait why are you trying to come away
I want to listen I want to listen so I
love it
right whenever you think you have
something when
it was life to begin with you have to
remember who can take your soul today
who can take your soul tomorrow right
this is a Creator in Islam Allah created
us and he's testing Us in this line I
already know about Islam though okay
you know oh so we so we become a Muslim
gonna have four to five wives
four to five lives you can't eat pork
okay you pray five times a day okay uh
the judge but if they the uh be the the
the the digital the digital somebody
help me out bro the Dodge I'm feeling
your trolling the brothers
too so religious religion for us is
Muslims is seriously you know that yeah
I'm sure you know that very well I'm
sure people in your community know that
very well you think Islam very serious I
did that we don't joke around we don't
troll when it comes to stop right we do
believe in Judgment Day Islam does not
teach that every Muslim should marry
four wives where do they get this
concept from no yeah somebody is
laughing I'm serious she's not with us
she's not with us
so if you read the Quran
and then he just gets dragged me away
someone else that looks like
so there there's definitely a lot going
on in that clip and
my first my first uh question was
you know what what happened so I want to
hear from your perspective what was
going on yes Paula this was like it's
obviously Allah has his plans you know
you just he just happened to walk across
I didn't even know who he was but at the
point is the interesting thing we need
to look at is his behavior and he's
approaching the tip right he was the
person walking and straight away the
verse of the Quran came to my mind Allah
says
do not walk in the earth boastful you're
not gonna the Earth is not gonna crack
open and you're not gonna reach the
height of the mountains so you cannot be
like walking like you like your own you
own the whole place right so he was
walking in that way and he's coming very
aggressively and the interesting
background story is this but before I
say the background story is that he went
to the brother who's talking with a
sister in one of my brothers who's
talking with a with a woman
that woman was coming to accept Islam
right she's ready to accept Islam she's
taking her child and he came and then he
embarged into the valley table jumping
on the brother and then he said what is
this
I don't know and the interesting thing
is is that we were already kind of on
the defensive anyways because you had
this woman from Speaker's Corner coming
with five people the videos of my
channel is one hour video you hear her
speaking in the video as well she was
there and she was coming with five
people with cameras so what happened
which is very funny is that I thought
speed was a guy who goes to Speakers
Corner who looks very very similar to
him he's he's got the similar hairstyle
and this and that and he's a part of
that group so I thought he was coming
with her and he's coming like this so I
said who are you are you coming like
interrupting the the brother is about to
take the shot of his sister you probably
like like this right so first thing I
said who are you right so then he said
speed I said okay speed and then I was
thinking in my mind you see me pause for
a second is why is he joking is a drug
who's called speed you know so then I I
said to him
what do you want right so then you see
how he's speaking now he is very
aggressive in his tone right calling me
buddy which is very very funny to be
honest but yeah that's why in that way
you have to kind of ignore these things
and you have to engage with the people
right I said okay alhamdulillah he's got
so many people around him I hear people
laughing some people saying troll troll
and trolling and this and that so I
thought he was being uh coming to jokes
so I said to him look first thing that
we need to keep in mind is that we're
not here to talk we take our religion
seriously and we mention the verse of
the Quran in the Stream is that we are
commanded not to engage with people if
they're coming to joke and mess around
about the religion of Islam we have to
be serious you have to say that we're
not going to engage so I said to him if
you're coming to Joe this is not what
what we're here to do he said no I'm
serious I want to learn I said okay
you're serious I saw people around him
tell me I said it's a chance for me to
talk about just basic concepts of Islam
that Allah is not like his creation
right Allah sends the prophets and
Messengers and we don't believe that God
is a man this misconception so I just
delivered these misconceptions and I
knew anyways this is not a good
opportunity to do the dawa
question is why is because when he came
there's already a hundred
children following him they surrounded
the whole table right there was already
this woman there and his managers were
trying to drag him away to leave because
they saw there's so many people crowding
and something problem might happen right
so you saw in the video they were
dragging him and I said no no leave him
to listen right he wants to say he's
want to listen let him don't don't take
him away so his managers were trying to
drag him so basically I delivered the
message and then all of a sudden when
I'm explaining to him he said why is
this I want to learn he said look now
the self-contradition I was mentioning
he said I want to learn then in mid
discussion he said I already know about
Islam right so now I see look if you
come into joke look he said he wanted to
learn in a video of this question now
you say you you know about Islam which
one is it right I say okay you know
about Islam I still would exercise
patience you okay tell me about Islam
then he goes and says five four five
five four or five fives and then he
mentions these jokes so I said look if
you're joking I said to you in the
beginning look we don't joke around with
Islam we're serious if you want to hear
we can talk to you then obviously that
woman she came and she said
this crazy Christian woman and then he
thought that that someone or someone
with us or something like that then I
said I'm serious I'm serious his manager
heard him uh with a loud voice so he
probably dragged him because so many
people were around and they left right
so this opportunity was definitely not
our opportunity you cannot give him that
way in the environment it's impossible
you're not going to be able to do it
because situation and how things were
and he's not going to spend a long time
there so I said alhamdulillah anyways I
was able later on when I found out who
he was I said hamdullah I was able to
deliver anything that maybe someone
heard that maybe someone would benefit a
misconception that can be moved away
from the people or something that might
aspark something in the mind of people
when they watch the video so that was
kind of uh the background what happened
you know yeah that's beautiful we only
have a few minutes and I don't want to
hold you past your thought how long do
you have exactly like four minutes or
something till you have to break no it's
okay we can we can do few minutes it's
okay go ahead because we have five Super
chats and uh go ahead go ahead no
problem any other questions okay I'm
with you
so we're gonna have uh we're gonna have
brother Muhammad read it yeah
yeah so he's praising Allah basically
um brother Raymond says I know you said
eye drops are okay but it's chapstick
I'm fine without using it but uh but for
the sake of Allah everyone looking at me
I feel bad okay one you're too insecure
about your lips don't worry I don't
think people are that focused he could
be a river bro he could be a river he's
just trying oh yeah
well anything that does not get consumed
into your stomach does not break your
fast but if you start using these type
of things it might be difficult for you
to avoid it
so obviously the best option is not to
use it but if you can guarantee using it
without swallowing any of it because if
you do it will break your fast because
it goes into your your stomach if it
goes into your stomach it breaks your
fast so that's that is the general
criteria to make it easier for you
um
all right RS says if we want to fund
Muhammad's dawah and share in the reward
how can we do so please consider adding
Muhammad to the group for Muslims
so if somebody wanted to fund your dawa
is there any way to do that
yeah alhamdulillah just just YouTube the
Muslim Lantern until I find all the
links there so you see the Muslim
Lantern there down when I'm speaking you
just type the Muslim Lantern inshallah
it's very easy
all right next one I can put myself in
the shoes of the non-muslim but I cannot
do that with the one who is attacking
because
um will mind my own business I'll have a
Time
I'll have a timer focus in attacking
Islam and yes I remember you
um it didn't want to enter where you're
from but it is a bit difficult but
that's why it's a skill that you have to
build over time you know and recognizing
if someone's attacking Islam like why
even engage with that person right
and and one important thing to keep in
mind is that not everyone can do that
and something we need to understand not
everyone can do when I say that I'm
talking about one to one street
engagement now everyone can do that in
different ways supporting the dawa
donating sending messages texting not
everyone can some people might have
literal anger issues
an individual like that cannot engage in
the dark like I know some people like
that we give them different tasks like a
film
stay away do this do that okay organize
the books he can do something else and
he himself will tell you I cannot
control my anger
so some individuals if they have certain
problems it can be a barrier from them
from doing this physical one to end our
that's why Allah did not just choose
anyone to deliver the message he chose
the best of creation to deliver the
message so we need to understand that
not everyone is able to do this
one-to-one as well
beautifully said beautifully put do I
have any more all right it's not like
them how can I how should I answer the
following question if someone asked it
yeah uh they asked what is my role if
Allah is the one who Guide Slash sends
people astray
yeah Allah says the same thing in the
Quran as he actually he answers it in
chapter 16
verse 100 and something I'm not
remembering exactly verse what but if
you search the verse that says Those Who
lie are those who don't believe in the
verses of Allah the next few verses will
explain to you Allah says that those
people well Allah seals their heart
are the people who choose this life over
the afterlife
so it's a consequence of their choice
also Allah says
Allah let their hearts go astray so you
need to understand it's a constant of
Qatar you need to understand what Qatar
is very well as a Muslim so one of the
pillars of your Iman or your faith you
need to understand it and we believe
that we have a choice and we believe
that Allah doesn't Force us
to do things which which deals with are
where we're going to end up in the
afterlife we choose to do this and in
the same time they're under Allah's will
and Allah's power and control Allah
Allah never misguides except those that
are divinely disobedient
so the people that you know not all the
time or the people that generally want
the truth and are seeking the truth and
making Dua for guidance because we know
the Duel of the audience is never
rejected absolutely
100 all right it's not like brothers one
of the problems I have got with my uh
Christian peers is that almost none of
them refer to their scriptures when
trying to counter my points to the point
where I run out of patience but not flip
out on them
foreign
I can only engage with you based on the
scripture that you believe in because
it's your presentation of your religion
and then you can say to them that if you
do not like believe in that scripture
then we can engage in a different way
like what I'll say something very
important and I want to mention that
because I just heard it recently one
brother doing that I'm not gonna mention
right but the point is the woman she's
coming and she asked him a question
about the Quran what he did is he
straight away went to the Bible okay
then that woman she said oh you know
very well about the Bible but you don't
know about your book right so the
problem is what we end up happening
today is people who are Bible scholars
we don't need them
they know nothing about Islam
and they only know about the Bible as
Muslims and they go they engage with the
Christians that's not dawah that's not
what dawa is that's not how dawa ever
was done you dawa is invitation to Islam
if you don't put forward Islam you're
not really doing that you're just
engaging in an intellectual discourse
with someone right and even the question
is even even permissible for you to be
reading the scriptures of the people of
the book without gaining basic knowledge
most of the scholars are saying to you
know and you can read what says about
that
explains the Hadith
why are you reading
why are you reading you don't need to
read it so you you're reading these
scriptures and going into details and
you don't even know anything about your
religion it's a big problem
um your religion comes first yeah
absolutely that's a very beautiful Point
honestly subhanallah I would love to
continue the conversation if you have
any more Super chats we could put out
but I think it's where you're at and I
don't want to be the reason for you not
breaking your fast ASAP because the sun
does to break it yeah
no we're done there's just two quick
ones uh please convert actual speed it's
not Allah who can it's not us who can
Ritz it's Allah we're open to having a
discussion with him if he's open
inshallah
um and then inshallah me and Rami uh
there's a question we'll answer but
we'll let the brother go inshallah it
was a pleasure yeah and and inshallah
extend the invitation as well to anyone
who is well known on social media who's
who is curious or interested to learn
about Islam anyone who even has a
history of even attacking Islam or
criticizing Islam we're able to have
intellectual and discussion with those
people they welcome anyone welcome
anytime insha Allah will make time for
you don't worry we fly over to your
country with whatever you need or yeah
engage with you inshallah when we come
to the UK inshallah we're going to come
through and meet you
all right so this question
what if this world is all we have or
what we have well I mean
uh alhamdulillah firstly we do have the
world Allah has put us here but he
didn't put us here without a reason
Allah he said he did not create Jinn or
mankind except to worship Allah and what
is worship worship is who you submit to
in every way and Allah commands us to
pray to him he commands us to fast for
him he commands us to do things
sincerely for his sake and to avoid
things for his sake and a part of
worship is obey obedience obeying Allah
over your own you know desires over the
other people who are trying to perhaps
misguide you away from Allah and as the
prophet peace be upon him he said there
is no obedience to the people with
disobedience to Allah so this world
alhamdulillah is um something that we
have actually been blessed with because
Allah has put us here to allow us to
elevate ourselves insha Allah in the
afterlife and for you to believe if if
you or anyone thinks that this world is
all we have
um I think that's actually very
problematic
because what was there before the world
and how did the world come to be in the
first place and after the world
dissipates and disappears or pops out of
existence
why would you not assume that something
else would come after that
you were nothing right you were nothing
at one point just like us we were
nothing we didn't exist we were
technically in a state of death because
we weren't alive and then boom all of a
sudden we came to life
just like that
and then we're going to die we know that
for a fact so why are we not going to
assume that we're going to come back to
life afterwards
when Allah he tells us very clearly in
the Quran he asked do you not think that
we're able to rise you again to raise
you again to replicate your entire body
even down to your very fingertips and
your your fingerprints subhanallah
look
all right all right guys comment down
below if you want us to bring back
brother Muhammad Ali the Muslim Lantern
smash that like button share this video
or stream with somebody that might
benefit or even if you don't think
they'll benefit but there's a
possibility they might share it
inshallah you got the reward that all of
us have gained which is the blessing and
wisdom and knowledge from this beautiful
brother inshallah and with this being
said brother Romi is there anything else
just a final da insha Allah may Allah
forgive us for our shortcomings and
reward us and accepts from us our Good
Deeds Allah I mean anything bad is from
ourselves in shaytan anything good is
from Allah may Allah forgive us and
allow us to be leaders for the righteous
I mean and with that being said